wie muss man sich das vorstellen wenn
man sich nicht impfen lässt muss man
dann wie hoch ist die geldstrafe was ist
das bußgeld da klopft dann zu hause
jemand und sagt jetzt kommen sie aber
und dann stehen die soldaten vor der tür
nach einer afghanin fall also das steht
ja noch nichts fest und ich kann hier
wirklich nicht also nach vorne blicken
weil ja gesundheitsminister teil der
regierung die regierung entscheidet das
nicht das ist eine frage des parlament
ist also wie das parlament quasi das
umsetzt aber natürlich also wird es so
sein dass der bußgelder eine rolle
spielen wie hoch das weiß man ich das
darüber möchte ich einfach nicht so
zitierfähig spekulieren weil ich möchte
einfach dem deutschen bundestag nicht
vorgreifen es wird auf jeden fall so
sein dass das also wenn wir das werden
wir diesen weg gehen und ich rate uns
diesen weg zu gehen damit wir zukünftige
schwere wellen nicht fürchten müssen ich
möchte einfach nicht alle drei bis vier
monate in etwas hinein kommen will jetzt
mit die gesamte regierung beginnt dort
ein wortbruch erst einmal das ist das
erste das zweite ist sie haben in dieser
woche davon gesprochen dass es nicht
genügend impfstoff gibt und weiterhin
wird über die impfpflicht geredet wir
wissen nicht mal wie viel wie booster
müssen das ist doch total absurd naja
ich habe eben ja eben schon vorgetragen
dass wir das impfstoffmangel problem
durch die lieferung von 25 millionen
dosen das sind 50 millionen dosen
lösen konnten ja aber sie wissen doch
gar nicht wenn jetzt auch mikron dann
kommt die nächste welle es gibt auch
fast schon im cup man muss sich dann
alle vier fünf sechs monate im vorjahr
das ist richtig aber wir haben jetzt
also tatsächlich eine kurzfristige
lieferung da bin ich sehr dankbar von
moderner bekommen 25 millionen dosen das
reicht für 50 millionen booster
impfungen damit kann man wirklich also
einer poster kampagne fahren aber wie
man kann man im deutschen wirklich
verpflichten sich jedes jahr neu impfen
zu lassen oder alle sechs monate kann
man das machen das ist ja wir haben es
hier im abo genannt ja also denken wir
mal darüber nach was wäre die
alternative
also ich will hier spreche ich wirklich
also aus als also als arzt und auch was
abgeordnete nicht aus der perspektive
des gesundheitsministers aber denken wir
dann was wäre die alternative
die alternative wäre dass wir bei jeder
neuen variante darüber diskutieren
müssen können wir die schule noch offen
halten müssen die geschäfte schließen
geht es dass wir den einkauf noch machen
muss wieder getestet aber die zahlen
sind ja gar nicht so klar laut ob auch
wir erleben dass es zum beispiel in
hamburg ein skandal gab weil peter
tschentscher insbesondere ungeimpfte
angeprangert hat und gesagt hat dass die
zahlen der infizierten beziehungsweise
auf der intensivstation besonders groß
sind ja das ist aber keine keine gute
also darstellungen und nachfrage weil
eine solche frage weil ihnen das nicht
gefällt und jetzt gefällt mir gut aber
ich will es richtig sehe also das
unterstellt ja könnte es sein dass eine
solche situation in ganz deutschland
vorherrscht und das in ganz deutschland
so ist dass die ungeimpften und
vielleicht gar nicht so einen großen
anteil haben vielleicht sind es ja doch
gegeben das ist ja sagen wir das
schwingt ja als unterton sondern einfach
eine praktische darstellung genau das
ist das schwingt aber in einer solchen
phase haben ihre interpretation also
über das jeder interpretiert er uns
zuhört und also ich sage das was in
hamburg passiert ist das so war ein also
das war ein missverständnis
aber wir wissen natürlich durch die
zahlen des robert-koch-instituts ganz
genau also wie sich die also situation
verhält und
offen gesagt
selbst wenn wir keine belastbare
statistik hätten es kann ihnen wirklich
jeder kliniker sagen da die intensiv
medizin dort betreibt dass die sehr
schwer erkrankten die ich also
ungeimpften sind und wenn es anders wäre
mehr ist ein wunder im übrigen